on this Saturday night Newfoundland
paralyzed the record-breaking snow and
the struggle to dig out I've never seen
nothing like this the provinces plea for
help with more snow on the way
royal resolution Megan and Harry cut a
deal with the Queen on alert the concern
over a new deadly virus that's spreading
Plus how the global elite plan to make
green mainstream
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us it was a storm for the history books
and tonight much of Newfoundland and
Labrador is buried in snow a blizzard
with hurricane-force winds whipped the
province yesterday and didn't let up st.
John's International Airport recorded
76.2 centimeters of snow that's the most
since record-keeping began in 1942 other
areas saw over 90 centimeters and the
fierce winds blowing all that snow
around created drifts that reached up to
rooftops the province has extended a
state of emergency for Saint John's and
surrounding areas into tomorrow and it
could remain in place until the start of
the week as Ross Lord reports it'll take
days for people on the rock to dig out
the worst snowstorm in decades is
finally over but its impact is only now
coming into view streets plugged with
snow cars covered and in some cases
buried deep beneath snowfall that was
accurately forecast but needs to be seen
to be believed no more buddy this is the
most I ever seen in my life
we got where do we put the snow for a
second day a state of emergency remained
in effect in Saint John's and in many
other Newfoundland communities tens of
thousands of Newfoundlanders have been
forced to endure power outages it was 12
about 12 hours
we lost fire for about 12 hours for
people in this neighborhood staying
inside didn't help police say an
avalanche of snow crashed into one home
spreading heavy snow inside and causing
firefighters to urge residents to move
to safety emergency responders say they
are available if required here
firefighters responded to an explosion
from an electrical transformer near the
top of a house fortunately there was no
serious damage in another community a
man who suffers from medical issues has
gone missing his family has not heard
from him since he left home on foot
Friday at the height of the blizzard a
big question can the province of
Newfoundland and Labrador handle the
cleanup alone the premier has asked the
federal government for help it could be
anything to providing assistance to
people that are left stranded in their
homes and there's quite a few of those
the state of emergency is still and then
extended in many parts of the problems
right now because of the accumulation of
snowfall so there will be a number of
things that they could be engaged in
where we can give relief and where we
can assist them that's very important
but also just for the general public to
know that their federal government is
acting with all the resources that it
can bring to bear as quickly as possible
in Bonavista another coastal community
in a state of emergency the snowfall
total is 71 centimeters
there were peak gusts of 164 kilometers
an hour to me the most frightening and
you know for me word winds still
incredible speed just everything shaken
was great Bona vistas mayor estimates it
will cost millions of dollars to repair
the damage including five sections of
seawall the
last the cold snap has moved in ensuring
all of this won't be going anywhere for
a while
Ross Lord global news Halifax for more
on the record-breaking snowstorm and
when Newfoundlanders can expect to see
some relief
let's bring in Global's Mike Arsenal
Mike hi Robin well the overall snowfall
totals from this storm are almost hard
to fathom as we take a look at nearly a
meter of snow fell in Mount Pearl in
paradise anywhere between 75 and 85
centimeters across the city of st.
John's now this isn't just the one-day
snowfall this includes some lingering
snowfall very early this morning and the
winds as Ross alluded to news report
Bonavista a hundred and sixty-four km/h
171 in a green island cape pine 146
killed near per hour wind gusts so it
was really a hurricane trapped in a
blizzard these were the conditions that
people across Newfoundland were dealing
with it is quiet right now
lots of sunshine cold temperatures as
people try to dig out but more active
weather is on the way
sunniest skies clear skies for today but
this storm bringing snow right now in
this evening into Ontario and into
Quebec will become a Sunday story in the
Maritimes and then another 10 to 15
centimeters for portions of Newfoundland
Environment Canada has issued a special
weather statement so still lots of
active weather for eastern Canada to
come Mike our snow in the global news
Weather Center thanks Mike and for more
on the storm including some of the
incredible photos and videos head to our
website global news dot CA / global
national and the storm system Mike
mentioned is already causing problems in
Toronto drivers are dealing with
potentially dangerous conditions they're
being warned visibility could change
suddenly because of heavy blowing snow
more than 200 accidents have already
been reported in the GTA
today's storm is expected to be the most
significant snowfall to hit the region
since November that powerful storm is
also hammering the u.s. tonight tens of
millions of Americans are under a winter
storm warning heavy snow and freezing
rain are causing treacherous travel
conditions from the Midwest
the Northeast more than a thousand
flights have been canceled and it's
chaos on the roads Jennifer Johnson
reports a massive winter storm plowing
across the u.s. millions of people put
under blizzard warnings as whiteout
conditions make traveling hazardous from
the plains to the Midwest this dramatic
video from a crash in Iowa a pickup
truck narrowly missing a delivery truck
driver whose vehicle had slid off the
highway police say if you have to be on
the road take precautions
turn on your hazards let other drivers
know that you're having an issue heavy
snow is being blamed on a deadly
avalanche Friday at the alpine meadow
ski resort in California killing 34 year
old cold Comstock skiers are still
heading to the slopes but being careful
usually it's only when there's tons of
new snow and you're trying to be out
there well that well that's coming down
and building up and I try to avoid being
out there when that's happening in
Minnesota first the snow now freezing
rain crews working around the clock to
keep the Minneapolis st. Paul Airport
open
we have bunk beds we would they eat at
the airport they sleep at the airport so
that we can make sure that they're
available to follow those runways in
Chicago the storm has caused hundreds of
flights to be cancelled Kansas City to
its Airport forced to shut down runways
because of a dangerous snow ice mix this
Delta flight slid off the tarmac
fortunately no one was injured some
football fans trying to fly to Missouri
are taking no chances skipping the skies
and hitting the road for an eight-hour
drive to get to the Titans Chiefs AFC
championship game by Sunday just hoping
there's no wreck so we can get there in
a timely manner and it's worth it for
this team big fans so got to do it more
snow and sleet are predicted from
Chicago to Buffalo to parts of New
England as this monster storm moves
north snow was predicted for the
Washington DC area but only small
amounts of freezing rain are expected
the Mid Atlantic dodging this event
still waiting for its first big
snowstorm of the winter
Robin Jennifer Johnson in Washington
there's developing news coming from
Buckingham Palace the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex will stop using their royal
highness titles and won't receive public
funds for rural duties that's part of a
deal Megan and Harry just struck with
the Queen ten days ago the couple
blindside of the royal family when they
they wanted to carve out new roles for
themselves and we're stepping back as
senior Royals to become financially
independent crystal commencing joins us
from London with the latest developments
in this family rift crystal Robin this
really is a bombshell announcement from
the palace the plan to become a regular
folks is Delon at least for the most
part now the term his imperial highness
will no longer be applied to Harry and
Megan however it's worth noting that are
not being stripped of that title now the
couple will no longer represent formally
represent the Queen they will also not
receive any public funds for royal
duties and in a statement from the
palace outlining the separation Harry
and Megan will have to repay about four
million dollars to the taxpayer here
money that was spent renovating their
home near Windsor Castle cottage in
terms of Canada and their security costs
which has been a big topic of discussion
here in Canada I think the fact that
there they are truly giving up that
title means that perhaps that concern by
the taxpayers commitment to security
costs and any other costs may be less if
if zero it's fine as long as we don't
have to pay anything for it I think
that's a pretty brave thing that they're
doing giving up that Dutch family
security that they've had this whole
their whole lives I think they're making
a choice for their family I think it's
both they're focused on their children
and the kind of life that they want for
them the Queen shared some thoughts
about the couple's new low-key life away
from the royal media spotlight and
official duties she said she was pleased
that together
we have found a constructive and
supportive way forward for my grandson
and his family Harry
Megan and Archie will always be
much-loved members of my family I
recognize the challenges they have
experienced as a result of intense
scrutiny over the last two years and
support their wish for a more
independent life she went on to say it
is my whole family's hope that today's
agreement allows them to start building
a happy and peaceful new life now this
statement comes after the Royals had
shared details about the separation as
Megan and Harry made their wishes know
that they wanted to step away from royal
duties now this isn't exactly what we
had first thought would be happening it
is a very clear separation from the
royal family and royal duties and it
appears as if they are getting exactly
what they wished or tongue and we'll be
seeing them
Christel commencing in London more
Canadian fire specialists have landed in
Australia to help the country fight the
wildfire crisis 28 Canadians touched
down in Melbourne joining dozens of
others already on the ground they'll
spend the next month as part of an
emergency response team for the state of
Victoria it's Canada sixth deployment to
Australia since December in total 172
firefighting personnel from Canada have
been committed to the wildfire crisis
conservation specialists in Australia
fear it's too late for the country's
unique wildlife which may never recover
experts say as many as a hundred
threatened species are closer to the
brink of extinction and estimate more
than a billion animals have been killed
the fires have burned more than a
million hectares of land u.s. President
Donald Trump is hoping to survive his
impeachment trial and secure a second
term the trial which resumes Tuesday has
overshadowed the race for Democrats to
choose a presidential candidate
but now Democrats hope the impeachment
trial will boost the party's chances of
taking back control of the country Eric
Sorenson reports the Republican Senate
may want the trial a president Trump to
come and go as quickly as possible but
it may not be as simple as all that a
drawn-out trial could set back Trump's
bid for re-election but a hasty trial
could also backfire on Republicans
running for re-election so says this
former Democratic presidential candidate
who spoke to us on the West block
they'll pay a huge price at the polls
there's five or six Republican senators
from swing states that are in some
jeopardy and covering up misdeeds that
the president is probably not a great
way to get reelected in places like
Maine but surely if this carries on for
some time that can't help the president
either no I think if it carries naught
it hurts the president Howard Dean says
with the primaries about to start next
month it is still a wide-open race for
at least a half a dozen Democrats to win
the party's nomination for President
Biden Sanders and Warren appear to be
the frontrunners Pete booter judge Amy
Klobuchar are still in it and the wild
card maybe former New York City Mayor
Michael Bloomberg Dean says it would be
a mistake to underestimate Trump's
potential to win reelection I think it's
a 50/50 jump ball right now I don't I
mean he is despised by half
of America but the other you know he's
got 40% there is essentially our cult
members and they're not gonna go
anywhere Dean says the key to a
Democratic win in November is motivation
if the major Democratic voting blocs the
african-americans Hispanic and Asian
Americans as well as women and young
people if they all get out the vote the
Democratic nominee whoever that may be
should win
Eric Sorenson Global News Ottawa and you
can watch the full interview with Howard
Dean tomorrow on the West block coming
up on global national the mysterious
virus that has major airports in Canada
on alert
a mysterious respiratory illness with
similarities to SARS has health care
workers around the world including here
in Canada on alert at least 45 people
have contracted the virus believed to be
connected to animals at a market in
central China there's growing concern
human-to-human transmission may be
possible and that's prompted three major
airports in Canada Toronto Vancouver and
Montreal to take precautionary measures
Brett T Cecchini reports in the middle
of an active cold and flu season public
health officials are now tracking a
possible epidemic after a new virus with
pneumonia like symptoms was discovered
with links to a market in China's Wuhan
province I understand they're doing some
mental investigation in the markets
known as coronavirus it comes from a
larger family that includes everything
from the common cold to SARS this strain
wasn't detected until early January when
a person was hospitalized with suspected
influenza it's really important in this
case to understand what the route of
exposure was what the actual identity of
the animal is at least three patients
who had traveled from central China have
been hospitalized in both Thailand and
Japan two are not believed to have been
at the market investigators must now
determine if the illness is spreading
through Wuhan but they don't have a
clear picture this isn't a time for
panic but it is a time for people to be
alert in the meantime the Chinese
government has ordered the suspected
market closed and is being given credit
by the World Health Organization for its
quick action Chinese authorities also
shared the complete genomic sequence
with whu-oh and in 2003 Chinese health
agencies actively worked to cover up the
details surrounding the SARS virus the
respiratory illness led to more than 750
deaths worldwide 44 of them in Canada
the highest number of deaths outside of
China and Hong Kong currently there is
no vaccination for coronavirus there are
immunotherapies that are under
consideration but that isn't enough for
some medical experts once SARS appeared
in 2003 and we knew that coronaviruses
had this potential it really was
imperative that we developed
countermeasures to be able to take
coronaviruses off the pandemic list and
it's now 17 years later and
we're seeing what happens when you don't
have vaccines these concerns come as
China prepares to welcome hundreds of
thousands of visitors for Lunar New Year
celebrations travel bans have not been
put in place in Wuhan province yet and
Canadian health officials have deemed
the risk to travelers as low while the
US Centers for Disease Control is
advising people to practice usual
precautions the best advice is to
probably avoid those live animal markets
in Wuhan in a protective move passengers
at local airports will have their
temperature screened well in the US
health officials at 311
regi Cecchini Global News still ahead
the major meeting make over the big
plans to leave a small footprint at
Davos
the Davos World Economic Forum kicks off
Monday the meeting brings together about
1,700 business leaders and 58 heads of
state the event is often criticized as a
networking party for the world elite but
this year's focus isn't exclusively
about business as Mike Armstrong
explains the goal is to make green
mainstream there is a sensitivity as
some of the richest and most powerful
men and women in the world prepare to
descend on Davos every year critics bash
the event for the hundreds of private
planes limos and luxury while perhaps
recognising the event is part of the
problem Davos is trying to be more green
close to 90 percent of the vehicles are
going to be electric local foods and non
meat protein meals will be offered and
carbon offsets are being bought to make
the event carbon neutral the forum's
founder says the goal is to make green
investment mainstream because it has to
be the world is in a state of emergency
and some Indo window to act is closing
fast the World Economic Forum knows
climate is an issue it released a survey
this week a poll of 750 experts and
decision-makers asking about the biggest
risks the world faces the top 5 answers
were all related to climate change in
the environment Davos is head of climate
initiatives says whether it's wildfires
floods or hurricanes people are seeing
what it means maybe a few years ago when
people were talking about the impacts of
climate change that was one thing it was
a theory but I think what we're now
seeing is
actual kind of reality of what it means
Davos 2020 is going to push companies to
go carbon neutral and some are making
the move already
Canada's Maple Leaf Foods announced in
November it was carbon neutral while
tech giant Microsoft made this
announcement Thursday today we are
making the commitment that by 2030
Microsoft will be carbon negative now
going carbon neutral isn't necessarily
easy German engineering giant Siemens
promise to be carbon neutral by 2030 but
it's under fire from environmentalists
this week over one of its contracts the
companies doing work for a coal mine in
Australia this protester calls the coal
contract a scandal and the company
hypocritical I shouldn't be up here the
Davos forum will have a returning face
Swedish activist Greta tone berg has
been invited back for a second year she
says she'll be urging world leaders to
abandon the fossil fuel economy Mike
Armstrong Global News it's a landmark
day for a VC First Nation that's been
fighting to stop the development of a
contentious ski resort land that was
once planned for the jumbo glacier ski
resort in southeastern BC is being
handed over to the two Naha first nation
today but to now how will be given 21
million dollars from Ottawa and private
foundations to manage the land as an
indigenous protected area the agreement
brings to an end a decade's long fight
that went all the way to the Supreme
Court but to Naha consider the land to
be sacred and argued construction would
drive away the grizzly bear spirit a
principal figure of their religious
beliefs up next Ottawa celebrates a
half-century of a winter tradition
if you live in Ottawa
it's time to sharpen your skates the
Rideau Canal opened to the public today
officially kicking off the skate waste
50th season it was the news everyone
wanted to hear in the nation's capital
and people wasted no time skating away
on the two kilometers section of ice the
opening is almost three weeks later than
last year but mild temperatures delayed
the start obviously he's very excited
and didn't seem to mind the cold
because it was minus 28 degrees with the
wind chill this morning and that is
global national for this Saturday I'm
Robin Gill tonight we leave you with a
lighter look at the people of
Newfoundland and Labrador keeping their
spirits up in the snowstorm from skiers
hitting the slopes on the streets of st.
John's Dead battening down the hatches
with their storm chips
it's a Twitter trend in every East Coast
storm has Atlantic Canadian stockpile
their favorite trips during storms as
you can see from these shelves it's
something they take very seriously and
there was even an ode to one of the
local meteorologists who provided
up-to-date information on the blizzard
[Music]
your predictions were right for this
city
[Music]